so this is this is a classic to unit
question highly likely to find something
like this they'll either ask you the
normal or the tangent sort of flip flops
but attack back and forth between them
year to year so how do we solve this
question the equation of a normal and
normal is a line that here we go let's
use this is a line that is perpendicular
to the tangent at that point so see how
this straight line is tangent it just
touches the curve the normal does the
opposite of just touching it both
straight through as directly as it
possibly can it's at right angles okay
so the way to find the normal is if you
know the gradient of the tangent which
we can use calculus for then you take
the negative reciprocal that'll give you
the gradient of the normal okay so let's
have a look at this the first part is to
find the derivative because that's how
I'm going to get the gradient
okay so you guys can help me do this the
derivative of the function here is going
to be yes that power comes down looks
good and then yeah fantastic so this is
not complicated to differentiate but
what do I do with this I want to find
not just the gradient function at any
time I want the gradient here right so I
say when x equals 1 the derivative has a
particular value okay so that particular
value will be I'm gonna substitute once
into all of this like that yes correct
so let me just finish this out six take
away eight will be negative two
okay so I've got a gradient I've got a
point but keep in mind this is not the
great in other normal this is the
gradient of the curve which means it's
the gradient of the tangent and I don't
want the grain of a tangent
I want the normal so I'm gonna say I'm
actually gonna write here this is the
gradient of the tangent like so
therefore the gradient of the normal is
gonna be the negative reciprocal of that
so that's going to be in this case the
negative reciprocal lumina you do so
it's 1/2 or
so now have a look all the information I
need is here I've got a point
I've got a gradient so I'm gonna put
this into point gradient form so you're
talking about why do I substitute in
this value yeah okay
so the key is to know what does this
mean and how do we use it
so what this means is this curve up here
its gradient changes all the time
because it's a curvy looking thing
sometimes it's steep sometimes it's
shallow sometimes it's going up
sometimes going down so this tells you
the gradient at any value of x but I
don't want the gradient of any value I
want the gradient there so I take that x
value because it's all in terms of X's
and I substitute you okay that gives me
the specific gradient at a specific spot
so dy/dx right is the general gradient
but at a particular spot the general
gradient is equal to a particular number
so therefore I substitute in and I get
that number out okay which is different
from saying for a different question
altogether if I just said dy on DX
equals two and I gave you no other
context okay what that means is you've
got some function and it's gradient is
always two everywhere it's to every one
they gave to every single exhale you
like you'll get that okay that has to be
a straight line that's the only kind of
function whose gradient never ever
changes okay in this case the gradient
does change but at the specific spot I'm
interested in that's why I say when x
equals 1 I get this we're putting this
into a point gradient form right so just
to finish out it's helpful to actually
say what you're doing see how here I
don't just have an equation and then
equal something I distinguish between
these two gradients with words and I'm
gonna do the same thing here therefore
the equation of the normal is
y minus y1 equals M outside of X minus
x1
are you happy I don't know what form
they asked you to get this in is a
general form slow gradient a nice little
slow gradient slope intercept form
anything particular so I sort of default
to general form because I don't like to
deal with fractions so therefore what I
would do is I just deal with that double
negative and then I multiply by two they
don't have to do with fractions so this
would become 2y plus 4x minus one and
only takes a bit of rearrangement to
show that X minus 2y minus five is the
equation okay